dans quelques heures justin trudeau sera
assermenté premier ministre est comme
son père l'a fait bien avant lui il fait
participer ses enfants à ces moments
exceptionnels avant que sa vie ne change
du tout au tout c'est à l'adresse de
cette visite guidée de la colline
parlementaire pour xavier huit ans et
est la grèce 6 ans une occasion aussi de
saluer leur grand père et vous pensez à
nouveau pensé à les prochaines étapes se
rendre au sommet de la tour du parlement
un montant et avant de quitter la
colline le passage obligé par le nouveau
bureau
voilà c'est le numéro de papa ça c'était
le bureau d'un grand papa pierre aussi
et c'est déjà maintenant le temps de se
changer pour ressembler davantage un
vrai premier ministre libyen
ça va faire des choses dans les
premières réponses aux questions il les
offre non pas aux journalistes mais à
des enfants dans les écoles d'un peu
partout au canada
nous avons un tout les la capacité
d'amener des gens de partout au pays à
découvrir ce magnifique pays dernier
moment d'intimité pour lui et la future
première dame était un type dans la
région
tous ces visages feront bientôt les
manchettes justin trudeau en profite
pour les encourager c'est un moment
d'equipe c'est un moment de d'être
ensemble pour travailler fort pour ce
pays puis on sait ce qu'on va faire on
va se rendre au travail enfants
une accolade chaleureuse avec le
gouverneur général
le compte à rebours a commencé la suite
de l'histoire
reste maintenant à écrire ici frédéric
arnould radio canada montréal